hi and welcome to our session where
we're going under the hood for google
cloud's data technologies
i'm leah jarrett and i'm a developer
advocate here at google cloud and i
focus on data analytics but today i'm
also joined by my colleague derek who
focuses on operational databases
today we're going to be talking about
two technologies
first spanner on the operational
databases side of things and the left
hand side of our screen
and then we're also going to focus on
bigquery our data warehouse for
analytical processing
and these are just a few of the pieces
in the broader google cloud data
ecosystem
integrations between both of these
products and other products that support
data fabric artificial intelligence and
business intelligence all go into making
it simple for data practitioners and
business users to power data driven
innovation using google cloud
so the story of both spanner and
bigquery starts with the evolution of
the separation of storage and compute
historically database systems have been
architected with tightly coupled storage
and compute
so there's a dependence on locally
attached storage because attaching
storage to a network would result in
higher latency
but more recently these constraints have
been lifted largely due to faster
networks which we're going to talk about
momentarily
so now with architecture like bigquery
and spanner we have a separation of
storage and compute
and this allows us to seamlessly scale
to meet your high throughput data needs
new compute nodes can easily be added to
handle large workloads and we don't need
to rebalance the data and ensure that a
local replica is stored on new nodes
so let's take a closer look at how our
distributed storage system colossus is
also faster reliable and cost effective
for you
so colossus is google's next generation
distributed file system
it manages stores and provides access to
all of your data for both bigquery and
spanner
its design enhances storage scalability
and improves availability availability
to handle the massive growth and data
needs
colossus introduced a distributed
metadata model that delivers a more
scalable and highly available system
with all this data stored remotely if a
single node fails there's no data lost
or even made temporarily unavailable
not to mention remote storage is
dramatically cheaper than local storage
and the proof is in the picture so not
only does colossus handle your first
party data stored in google cloud but it
also stores the information needed to
run vital google systems that are used
by so many people all over the world
like we mentioned earlier the separation
of storage and compute would not be
possible without the evolution of
networks which increase the speed at
which compute clusters can pull data
from storage and reduce latency just
like colossus google cloud services like
bigquery and spanner leverage the same
network that powers the underpinnings of
google's systems
and we call this network jupiter
so jupiter is made up of an in-house
custom network hardware and software and
it connects all of the servers in our
data centers together
powering our distributed computing and
storage systems
so we discussed our file system and the
network that connects the storage and
compute together
now leading all the operations in our
data center is borg google's internal
cluster management system and the
predecessor to kubernetes
so bohr goes ahead and provisions the
needed compute resources to handle
workloads for spanner and bigquery
running hundreds of thousands of jobs
and making computing much more efficient
this allows our data centers to run a
really high utilization
so now let's see how these pieces come
together throughout the life of your
data
so let's take a look at symbol gaming
our fake gaming company who uses spanner
to support transactional or oltp
workloads
so a new user might log into the spanner
game and enter their information
this data is then sent to colossus for
storage but it's going to be in
spanner's file format
next this data is requested in a query
sent through spanner's compute engine
and finally the results of the query
will be returned in the application to
populate the new user's profile when
they load the page so spanner storage
and compute are both going to be
optimized for those transactional
workloads and derek is going to talk
more about that in a minute
so even though symbol is using spanner
for transactional workloads they also
want to perform analytics on this
information to understand how users are
actually playing their game
but for analytical workloads they're
going to instead use bigquery
so once the user's data lands in spanner
they have two options
first they can replicate the data in
bigquery storage by pushing new rows
into the native bigquery table
this is going to provide optimized
storage for analytics
on the other hand they can use a
federated query sent from bigquery over
to spanner so that they get real-time
access to information from their
application
either way they'll benefit from
bigquery's query engine to perform
scalable analyses including built-in
machine learning capabilities that power
business intelligence reporting and real
decision making from business users
so now that you understand how bigquery
and spanner both come together to
support your data needs let's talk about
how spanner is actually optimized for
those transactional workloads so derek
over to you
great thanks leah
cloud spanner is google's fully managed
distributed relational database
spanner provides customers with minimal
operational overhead with no downtime
for schema changes or even maintenance
windows
this allows spanner to provide an
industry-leading five nines sla
because spanner is distributed database
it provides seamless replication and
scaling across regions in google cloud
spanner processes over 1 billion
requests per second at peak
and all of that as a relational database
that provides strong external
consistency
made possible by the technologies
mentioned earlier borg colossus and
jupiter
to set up an example imagine that symbol
games has developed a game that will be
played by people all around the world
these players must be able to sign up
authenticate and play the game
players really don't like to have to
redo actions so this activity has to
have traditional consistency guarantees
another thing players don't like is
downtime
if they can't play they get upset
and it better be fast
so simple games will need to have the
ability to scale up to meet user demand
with availability consistency and
scalability in mind let's see how cloud
spanner can help them achieve their
goals
when you create a spanner node you get
access to spanner resources in three or
more zones
zones are borg cells these cells are a
collection of spanner resources that are
physically separate from other cells
spanner resources consist of spanner
servers and colossus allocations of data
storage
as discussed previously
spanner servers provide the compute
capacity for your cluster and they
contain the span process paxos and other
board tasks to enable google sres to
manage the environment
the zones can be within a single region
as shown here or across multiple regions
if you have a regional configuration you
have zones close together that provide
the lowest read and write latencies but
you only get an sla of four nines
availability
in a multi-regional configuration your
zones are located farther apart which
can increase latencies but it provides
global scalability and an sla of five
nines availability
now imagine that simple games has a
table of users
the user data is stored on colossus and
encrypted at rest
a copy of this data is in at least three
zones
and replication of the rights is handled
synchronously by paxos consensus
so their data will survive zone outages
and allows for zero time
zero downtime maintenances as well
to understand consistency let's go over
typical transaction life cycles
when a new user signs up symbol games
issues an insert statement to spanner
since nodes exist in multiple zones
where the insert statement hits depends
on which zone is the current paxos
leader
in this example zone 2 is our leader
a single endpoint is exposed to the
client and spanner internals handles
routing of the query
when the leader receives the write it
acquires locks and generates a true time
commit timestamp
then it sends the write to other nodes
in the configuration
these nodes write the mutation to
something like a durable transaction log
and confirm the write to the leader
after a quorum of nodes approves the
right then the leader tells the nodes to
commit the data it releases the locks
and returns the success to the client
all of this usually happens within a few
milliseconds
we can't do a session about spanner
without mentioning true time truetime is
a highly available internal service
backed by a network of atomic and gps
masters
this service can be called to generate a
guaranteed monotonically increasing
timestamp with microsecond granularity
across all nodes
in spanner these timestamps are
generated for writes
it is precisely because of true time
commit timestamps that allows a
distributed database like spanner to
ensure strong external consistency
so let's see how they are used for reads
once a user account has been created
they'd want to be able to log in and
start playing
so symbol games needs a consistent read
to provide authentication for the user
in this example the read is going to be
executed against zone 1
since it's closest to the client making
the request
but since zone 2 is a leader zone 1
checks in to make sure it has the latest
commit data
if the data is the latest it can be
returned to the client otherwise the
read waits until the node receives
updates
how does the replica know that it has
the latest data
with true time commit timestamps
the replica compares its own true time
state with the latest commit timestamp
to know if it's enough
up to date to serve the read
but not all reads of the user need to be
strongly consistent
since user data doesn't change that
often symbol games can choose to issue a
time-bound read otherwise known as a
stale read
to do this they provide the max age that
is acceptable for their query making it
time-bound
this allows the spanner node closest to
the client to respond to the query
without incurring additional round-trip
latency communicating with the paxos
leader
no matter how fast the jupyter network
is if you can cut out latency across
zones you should
with availability and consistency
covered simple games still need
scalability out of spanner so let's look
at that
as a first step simple games gets closer
to launch they can go ahead and increase
the number of nodes from pre-prod levels
to prod levels simply by updating the
cloud console
next as the user data grows spanner will
start to create splits of the data it
does this both by detecting cpu load
increases and hotspots
and will split the data into chunks to
address these issues
these splits can be hosted on different
spanner servers backed by different
colossus allocations which helps
distribute the load
data splits and increasing the number of
spanner nodes gives simple games the
ability to scale as much as they need to
but to avoid headaches down the road
they need to be sure to place related
data in the same split using
interleaving
imagine user activity data that relates
to the user data
by interleaving the user activity table
with the user table spanner will change
the splitting logic to make sure that
the data stays together on colossus
in this way spanner scales easily while
also keeping performance high by
avoiding additional locking required to
read or write across multiple splits
managing this distributed database for
transactional workloads is only possible
because of technologies like truetime
borg colossus and jupiter
so now leia's going to take it over and
talk about analytical workloads
great thanks derek
so now that you understand how spanner
is great and optimized for transactional
workloads let's talk about how
bigquery's architecture supports
analytical workloads
so let's start by adding the new user
data into a native bigquery user table
as soon as you push data into a native
bigquery table the data is going to be
transformed into a file format called
capacitor
uses what we call columnar oriented
storage meaning each column in the table
is going to be stored in a different
area of the file
so the amount of the columns you query
is going to be proportional to the
amount of data that's actually scanned
now if you think about it this is
optimal for analytics because you're
often aggregating just a few columns
over lots and lots of different rows
plus each column also has independently
compressed information
here we use different types of encodings
to optimize storage which makes it
easier for dremel our query engine to
quickly find and use the data it needs
for your query
even better you can choose to cluster or
partition your data stored in capacitor
so that dremel can easily eliminate
certain files or blocks from the query
let's look at a quick example of this so
let's say we have our user table and
we've decided to partition based on the
date that the user was created
we're also clustering or sorting our
table based on the game id
so now when we filter our data based on
created date and game id dremel is going
to use the file headings in capacitor to
reject the entire file or file block if
it's not needed for the query
this means that less data is going to be
scanned and your query is going to be
both cheaper and faster
so in colossus your data is stored in
capacitor and it's going to be
automatically compressed encrypted
replicated and distributed
so 100 of your data is going to be
encrypted at rest just like derek
mentioned with spanner
and colossus is also going to ensure
durability using something called
erasure encoding which stores redundant
chunks of data on multiple physical
disks
so immediately upon writing data to
colossus bigquery is going to start this
geo-replication process mirroring all of
the data into different data centers
around the specified region or
multi-region depending on how you set up
your bigquery data set
this means that you have backups of your
data stored in case of disk failure or
data center outages
okay so we talked a little bit about
bigquery storage now let's talk about
compute
so dremel bigquery's query engine is
made up of something called slots and
these are google's proprietary units of
cpu ram and network and they're used to
execute the sql queries
so bigquery will automatically calculate
how many slots are required by each
query depending on the data size and the
complexity of the query itself
you can think of a slot as a worker and
slots are going to be responsible for
executing parts of the active query
independently and in parallel and
they're going to perform partial
aggregations they'll also read and write
data back to storage
so the awesome thing about bigquery's
architecture is that you can actually
purchase slots and reserve them for
certain workloads in your organization
this means that you can scale your
throughput and your runtime as needed
so now let's go a little bit deeper into
query execution
first when you submit a query bigquery
is going to break it down into different
stages which will be processed by those
slots
intermediary results are going to be
written back to what we call the remote
memory shuffle since data here is
usually stored in memory it's really
fast for slots to read and write data
from the shuffle
now each shuffled row can be consumed by
slots as soon as it's created
this makes it possible to execute
distributed operations in a parallel
pipeline which means that we can analyze
huge amounts of data really fast
and if a worker were to have an issue
during query processing another worker
could actually simply pick up from where
the previous one left off because
they're able to read from the previous
shuffle
so this adds an extra layer of
resilience to failures within the
workers themselves
okay so let's say we're running a query
to count how many users join symbol
games yesterday before feeding them into
our ml model
in the first stage of the query slots
will read the columnar files from
colossus in parallel
each slot processes a columnar file
block filters the data and then writes
the partial aggregations to the shuffle
in the next stage a slot reads the data
from the shuffle and combines those
partial aggregations together
then it's going to write the results
back to colossus so that it can be
served as a cache table back to our user
so how do these architectural
distinctions of bigquery actually
translate to business value for you
well first of all we talked about how
bigquery's optimized storage and compute
allows for super fast queries over huge
data volumes
meaning your business will be empowered
to make informed decisions without ever
missing a beat
next we showed how bigquery helps you
save money on data storage and analysis
so you spend less resources answering
business critical questions
we also talked about how bigquery
storage ensures reliability and
durability meaning there's a very low
risk of losing information and
interrupting business processes
and finally the ability to purchase and
dedicate slots to specific workloads
means you can scale throughput and run
time so that you continue to support
your business analytics as your data and
your use cases grow
and don't just take our word for it
google cloud actually has hundreds of
bigquery customers with petabyte-scale
data warehouses
so thanks derek for walking us through
spanner and thank you all so much for
joining us today to dig into spanner and
bigquery under the hood
here we've provided some resources to
help you get started using both spanner
and bigquery and i've also listed some
sessions that are going on at next
related to data analytics and databases
so thanks again for joining us and we
hope you enjoyed this session and that
you enjoy the rest of your time spent
here at next
you